oh thank and exclusive hey it's hot 975
bootleg cab live in studio right now
Swizzy Showtime what's up brother man
how you doing man you know I'm just
visiting your town you know we're in 10
we gotta come say what's up yes sir
how's everything been man you've been a
busy guy as a way I mean you're you're
always a busy guy what can I say man I'm
just trying to have fun you know
maintain having fun you know is it's
hard to maintain having fun when you
started so so young and you never seen
everything you didn't did a lot of stuff
but I just continue finding ways to have
fun it seems like you are the question
be like the richest man in the world I
always see Swizz Beatz is always doing
some sort of new business venture it's
like man Swizz Beatz is really trying to
take over the world right now definitely
more more of a renaissance man in the
richest man in the world you know I
learned that um I learned come on my
wife without a song and it speaks about
when I get in detail and she killed me
you know it speaks about your song yeah
okay yeah it speaks about you know some
people some people are so poor all they
have is money ah you see I'm saying
right right right you know what good as
we're good as a castle if you feel only
that's true you say I'm saying so I try
to look to make history and be a
renaissance man for fire generation
that's a beautiful thing show people
that you know coming from South Bronx
are coming from not having nothing you
can design cause clothes whatever you
want to do music you know yeah and you
got you gotta the reebok you really i
didn't think reebok could be hot again
but you certainly are responsible for
that man is I gotta send you some stuff
do I got these busted ass Chuck's
goddamn questions bro but those classics
don't know that's my thing is Chuck
Taylors those are the sneakers that you
cannot you can if they're dirty is all
good all good and they're like 40 bucks
oh good but nonetheless you sign my boy
Mike Posner remember last time you were
here me and Mike and you were well now
easy I was fun as crazy I was the first
time I met him was was here with job he
played that Oprah on air I remember that
we was doing crazy having fun now you
know mike is he's mr. reebok mr. reebok
global I gotta get some of that love man
just you know the first time I ever
encountered you was in Phoenix you and
Cassidy came by the radio station you
brought a bunch of Pro Keds i believe it
was Swiss be yeah yeah those are my
first joints yeah I didn't get a pair of
those because I was uh I was just a
nobody i was in turn you know he said
spoke up no i was not my time at that
time but a man i'll take a pair of
Reeboks you know if you got you know
what I'm saying we got we got a wii
bringing back all the retros you know
shout to allen iverson on the
twenty-fifth we dropped those on the
twenty-fifth the questions are dropping
yeah are you guys in a retro all your
sneakers in retro and everything yo can
we get the classic Sean camps back
holiday when I say everything smooth
everything Shawn Kid Shawn Kemp's to
Shaq attaq see shaqnosis you know the
sneakers that Browns thought which ones
are the ones the joints I remember when
I was a kid I had the reeboks that came
with the pump you had to pump motor one
that with day with the basketball oh
yeah those are those are those are the
extra extra classics those are classic
those are like the big heavy space boots
yup yeah that's what it is bad hey so
let's talk about the music man this
street not record yeah it is a man it's
it's one of those songs that comes on
and then you get that like real ugly
face up mmm it just is it knocks I mean
it's the most of appropriate song title
it knocks bro is crazy it's crazy
because I named it that like right when
I was sending it out I was like they'll
put it let's put this joint I was like
what's the name loser streetman yeah now
call ASAP I was like y alma just name
the journey street like you do with that
you say hell yeah that's you know that's
that's that's appropriate it is I just
felt like at that particular time
listening to us out there you know I
just wanted something that felt like
it's fresh just at that frown face but
still new you know shout to a rap as
well you know for bringing that back you
know off for the UM tracked me and drag
had spit these bars you know and then
for a grab to show love and bring that
sound back united stood it was a dope
integration with the new indeed indeed
um when you I mean right now you're
you're kind of the whole musics you're
such a busy dude man when you make beats
other artists you got your solo stuff
going on I mean how do you separate the
two I mean like I know you were just in
the studio with Ross you're in the
studio with knives and I know you got
your own you know of course you got that
your own record out now i'm sure you're
working on a new album when you make
beats for other artists as opposed to
working on your personal project cycle
where is the fine line where you're like
ah this is this is so ill I'm gonna keep
this one oh you're understand when one
thing about me is I'm not I'm not a
greedy producer right you know I know I
know what my job first is my job is a
producer you know and if I gotta pull
something off my Island to give to
somebody that I respect his eyes that I
know that's gonna take it to the next
level it's my job to give it to them but
if I feel that it's not gonna come out
for a while or the people need to hear
this or whatever then I keep on like you
know what let me just rock with this and
just go with it right if I want my voice
to be heard or you know if I just want
to just put a sound out there because to
me is not about being the best rapper I
know I'm far from being brass rap I just
have fun you know so like when people
start comparing me to like other artists
and rappers and like I'm not innately
I'm anyways I'm just making music I'm
just making music I'm saying what's on
my mind I don't even write like you know
I'm off top of the head on everything
you ever heard you know from the biggest
courses to the freestyles to you know
goes right into everything like it's all
how I feel because music is an
expression right you know just like I is
an expression and some people can relate
to that expression and some people can't
that's why you have different genres of
music indeed you know indeed man yeah I
feel like some some producers like if
they're working on like something for
their camp or their or their project hmm
I feel like there are certain producers
that like you know that you could give
away your hottest beat and it's just I
mean all you gotta do is go back in the
studio and then and you you just made
your new hottest beat your honor I mean
it was tougher when when we had to click
him saying it was tough when when Rough
Riders you know in full effect yeah you
know it was it got real political and a
couple of points for giving away tracks
because I was putting out competition
you were helping the competition yeah it
was like I'm going against we fighting
against ourselves but now you know it's
not really like that you know now if I
give some ways like
so Australia you can be transcended all
that stuff it's show time it's a
beautiful thing full service records man
you you had your Rumble full surface
with Cassidy yeah young one bone thugs
and harmony yeah which I thought was a
good album I was fun I was fun we did
plant them off that that was that was a
blessing as well um what I know you full
surface really isn't in business anymore
are you just disintegrated all of that
you know um I just felt like I needed to
graduate you know things that I was
doing you know I just called 2010 my
graduation year spiritually mentally
everything and you know I just wanted to
rebrand my brand right and I just
thought that the things that I was doing
at that time was too trendy use it was
just like moving too much in the old way
of doing things it definitely i hear you
on the you know and it became like the
babysitting Club with all these artists
and all of that even though we had a lot
of fun though still like a lot of
pressure on me it was a lot of work and
you know i didn't see where the
financial part was making sense for all
that stuff i was putting in so you know
you only have 24 hours in the day and
you gotta figure out what you're gonna
do to feed your family what you're going
to do the tape to the next level and i
had to clear my table off of everything
that i was doing put things on my table
that I love doing for really when I wake
up in the morning I'm cool because
everything I'm doing to have a passion
for and it set up the right way and
that's why people got to see Swizz Beatz
reinvent as bringing reebok back team
you know doing Christian Louboutins and
doing Aston Martin's Lotus autumn our
watches and Basquiat I you know just
being like that's what I really wanted
to do damage so I had to regroup um 09
was like kind of like a big year for you
production wise it was kind of like I
think 09 you had a bunch of joints it
kind of reminded everybody like damn
swizz beatz I know you had to honor the
next one may know joint on a stone mom I
would say like as of late there hasn't
been that much Swiss production floating
around mmm is that like our purpose
definitely hell yeah Superman purpose
because that you got to let people you
know people that you got to give people
breathing
sometimes yeah because you know that's
why I stopped monster Mondays because we
spoil the fans so much that they don't
appreciate the craft after a while they
feel like I'm getting some every monday
is awesome aah yeah there's some heat
dropping on there monday yeah yeah yeah
I'm saying I that was my hardest job
ever to this day was doing monster
Monday's you know having the get to
artists get the track get the cars late
mix it boom boom before Monday you know
I did like 37 time to get paid with my
drawing that DMX record that you can't
that Jen was fun but I just felt like
you know I just wanted to give people a
timeout but I got a lot of stuff coming
out I'm saying like my stuff is always
timed in groups so you thought you're
gonna hit an odds you're gonna hear you
know the street knife this one that one
so you know most of my sound is based
off of my artists are coming up right
right right um what about wifey man you
got any are you gonna be working wife
you under new project yeah we vibed on a
couple of joints um she's about
ninety-five percent done what have them
I stoutly environment but she has such
an amazing vibe and creativity in the
world jeans a new Alicia album this
album is how that this album was a
game-changing that's what's up this is
this is a timeless piece that's just
album last night was a timeless piece
it's crazy like being that you know
she's your wife in like you know my
Kelly are you a wife is project I mean
it if that process like if you guys are
in the studio together I mean how
different it I mean that's got to be
very like it just got to be kind of
weird van do you know no you know
honestly it's like being in the studio
with any other talented artist right you
know it's the same process you know
she's a Caesar creative genius so it's
easy to work with her I know she writes
her song so it's easy to work with her
it's just a easy flowing vibe like you
know we never really get caught up into
the what you gotta do what you must do
what I need it's just violet you're
tryna or that's crazy well if we just
add that there on what if you do this by
my what I sound ok Bo it's a Swiss like
stoked it's the easiest seamless yes
easy accession how's the baby doing man
he's good he's good
you wanna now right sure you about to be
too easily where he bought me 19 months
he's doing he's out of New York doing uh
the aids walk right now with his
grandmother oh I stoked man putting them
into you know you probably flies
two-year-old on the planet to that we do
it big him and his brothers in this
isn't they do it big ya go you probably
reebok out definite hahaha you know he
right here I variety of things that's
what's up of course you know Swizz Beatz
he's probably got you know the hottest
like Louis Vuitton baby gear out do
everything no got it she would think
with kids like everything don't gotta be
named branches gonna be first utiful you
know I'm saying that you could take so
they get to a certain age they can just
turn me then it's like that I need I
can't want to wear that talk about I
need Jordans now this bomb on I come on
man come on um so you production-wise
you got your new album can we talk about
the album where the ASAP Rocky joint
that's gonna end up on your third album
um you know this is this is the fight
that I'm having you know the fight i'm
having is graduating from the old
mindset to and embracing the new mindset
which I've totally done but getting
people to understand and figure out
what's the formula today you know so as
far as the album and putting out a howl
I'm not excited to put out I'll I'm
excited to put out moments I'm excited
to put out great sounds you know
whenever I feel like it like as far as
putting a date down and just releasing
everything on one date that just don't
seem like fun for me yeah I'm saying
like maybe for other artists you know
like like a way nor Kanye you know
people that's masses at those things but
like me you know if you think about
Swizz Beatz I give people great moments
you know great moments in the club great
moments on radio you know great moments
in the video games am saying so I know
my strong points in and I think that
sometimes you gotta you gotta adjust
things to which widget what are your
strong points you know are looking out
yeah what they looking out for people
don't want to hear like a whole bunch of
Records with me rapping like I know that
yeah I'm saying like but people would
accept
the moments like okay that's dope birds
of yeah they like that my already like
that and then and mix that with me being
on other people's album I'm satisfied
with that you know I'm saying like I'm
satisfied with her I'm not trying to
compete with nobody you know I'm just
trying to just show people how I'm
graduating and I'm having fun and
encouraging them to do the same